all right everybody let's finish up with
a heartwarming story I'm pretty sure
you're going to love this is what I'm
liking for six years retired California
fire captain Shane Porter bonded with
his sons working together to restore a
1969 Jeepster it was a passion project
that came to a halt last year when Shane
passed away that is until a local high
school teacher volunteered to have his
class take over the project now a year
later the Jeep looks brand new knew and
Shane's family couldn't be more grateful
we have Shane's wife Tigger on the line
right now along with Bob the high school
teacher who took on the project they
watch on NBC4 Los Angeles what's going
on
y'all hi Cy oh my gosh that Jer is so
cool so Bob how did this all start well
everyone knows the porter family uh in
town they're amazing family they do so
much for the community and so much for
the school district and I've known them
for years when Shane passed away I was
helping tiger at the house saw the Jeeps
are in the garage and she told me about
the restoration project I'm an
automotive uh technology instructor and
came back to my class talked to my
advanced class and they said we have to
do this for the family it was not even a
question we did a 15-month restoration
on it and when we gave it back to the
family uh it was a very emotional day
and it wasn't a dry eye in the house oh
my gosh what a special class of kids you
got that's amazing and tiger what a
beautiful surprise for you right oh yes
yes you know what these kids had no idea
who I was what we did what you know
paramedic and they have no idea you know
anything about us but they did this out
of the kindness of their heart and they
did this because of Bobby's teaching um
my uh boys are gone now um my oldest is
in the Air Force and my youngest is in
the Army and
shame so I'm alone now so when I need it
the most I just get in the Jeep and and
I drive and it's like we're all together
[Applause]
again I mean I love that life works out
like that and by the way thank you so
much please tell your sons thank you so
much for their service first of all now
you have this beautiful reminder every
time you get in this vehicle like
they're still with you in some way um
Bob thank you so much for being such an
incredible teacher first of all teachers
make the world go round so thank you for
that your class is incredible tiger you
probably look so badass in that Jeepster
I'm not kidding girl you probably look
so fly driving around in that I'm like
I'm not only liking I'm loving your post
right now guys all right oh thank you
thank you thank you and that's not all
our season long partner pilot pin makers
of friction the go-to erasable pin of
the Kelly Clarkson show want to
celebrate teachers like Bob instilling
such kindness and thoughtfulness into
his students so they are giving Bob
$1,000
just
thank you guys so much beautiful
beautiful people thank you for joining
us thank you to all our guests this our
Josh Gad Andrew rolds David O and Nicole
Avon y'all have a great day it's not
[Music]
[Applause]
try thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home